This Valentine's pillow is shaped
as it's knit on the machine.
No cut 'n sew for this project, there are
two methods you can use to create your
knitting instructions for your gauge.
Use DesignaKnit and create your shape or
draw a template and work out the shaping
it with paper and pencil.
Tutorials for both of these
methods are available.
This video will focus on the
knitting and shaping of this pillow.
Take a look at the drawing for my pillow
at my gauge, and you'll notice that I need
to start with one stitch.
I don't know about you, but starting with
a single stitch and increasing to create a
V shape isn't one of my
favorite things to do.
Here's a better way.
Use short rows.
The widest point of my heart is 104
stitches all cast on those 104 stitches
with waste yarn and ravel cord.
Next, I'll e-wrap across all of
the needles with the main yarn.
After I finished the initial e-wrap, I
broke the yarn and removed it from the
carriage.
I'm going to start with a new end
of yarn in the center of the bed.
Now to make things a little easier, I
e-wrap cast on two stitches and then hand
knit those two stitches
through the original cast on.
You notice, I'll position my working yarn
over the needles in hold and I'll thread
up the carriage.
Then I've set my carriage to hold position
and I'll start knitting from the center of
the bed.
With each row knit, I'll follow my
pattern, putting needles in work to
increase and form the V shape.
Notice that you'll need some weight in the
center as you knit to keep those stitches
from popping off
because this edge will be enclosed
in a seam to create my pillow,
I'm not worrying about wrapping stitches
as you normally would with short rows.
I'll keep following my chart until all
of the stitches are in working position.
Then I'll turn off the hold setting and
at the straight section of my design.
When I get to the shaping for the top of
the heart, I'm going to split the row and
shape one side at a time.
You could remove half of the stitches on
waste yarn, but because this section is
fairly short, I'm just going to hang a bit
of waste knitting on the needles in hold.
This will protect the knitting from
the carriage as I work the other side.
Working on the right side of my heart.
I'll keep those left stitches inhold
position and set the carriage to hold.
Then again, following the diagram, I'll
decrease on both sides as I knit forming
that curved shape to make seaming easier,
I like to work my decreases one or two
stitches in from the edge.
Continue the shaping
according to your pattern.
Bind off the last row
and you're halfway there.
Remove the protective swatch and shape the
left side of the knitting to mirror the
right.
Voila.
A beautiful heart shape.
Knit a second one to finish up.
When you remove the waste yarnamfrom the
bottom edge, it'll be beautiful and easy
to see.
In the next video, we'll seam,
stuff and embellish the pillow